Зараз ми у ведмежому притулку «Домажир».
Це територія, яка є частиною біорезервату «Розточчя».
Саме тут наші колеги з Австрії, міжнародний фонд
«Чотири лапи» вирішили організувати
новий проєкт, який називається
ведмежий притулок «Домажир».
Україна має великі проблеми з утриманням бурого ведмедя,
який є в Червоній книзі, українській Червоній книзі.
Тому що в нас, буквально,
в живій природі залишилося
близько 200 особин, приблизно
така сама кількість проживає ще в неволі.
Я сказав би, що у дуже жахливих умовах,
тому ми утримуємо їх тут, даємо їм друге життя, друге дихання.
На 100 % ми відновити ці всі умови ми не можемо,
тому що тварина, яка побувала в неволі,
вона вже, на жаль, ніколи не вернеться до дикої природи.
В нас тут у цьому вольєрі, який десь приблизно 1,5 гектара
в нас два ведмеді — Тайсон і Машутка,
які живуть у своєму вольєрі.
Вони прибули до нас:
Тайсон з мисливської станції біля Коломиї,
а Машутка жила приватно, на ній тренували собак.
Коли ми їх привезли що одного, що другого,
вони не відчували і не знали,
що таке дотик землі чи відчуття трави.
Тому тут вони себе відчувають як на курорті.
Зазвичай вони дуже активні зранку і в кінці дня,
тобто сонце вже більше не припікає —
вони стають активнішими.
Серед дня дуже часто вони
можуть спати, наші тваринки,
навіть відвідувачам ми не гарантуємо,
чи вони побачуть всіх.
Тому що мають свої теж такі безпечні місця.
Ми також їм допомогли збудувати барлоги.
Сподіваємося, вони будуть цієї зими спати в них.
Ну вот якраз відбувається процес приготування їжі.
Роман — це наш доглядач за тваринами, везе їжу.
Настя супроводжує його, тому що вона знає,
що сьогодні їжа буде подана біля басейну, мабуть.
Ось типовий набір їжі для наших тварин,  це їхня вечеря.
Це наші наймолодші ведмеді — Бодя і Настя.
Вони друзі, вони разом впадають в зимову сплячку.
Ми їм допомогли привезти соломи.
Настя, як справжня жінка, затягувала
тюки соломи всередину, в барліг,
Бодя тоді лежав на спині і
в нього був невеличкий шматочок дерева,
він його пробував перекидати з лапи на лапу.
«Ти така красуня!».
Вона така кругленька.
«Ти так гарно виглядаєш».
Тільки вона дуже ревнива до цих ведмедиків,
які живуть в сусідньому вольєрі.
Вона звикла домінувати, навіть інколи
звикла домінувати над Бодьою,
і, ну, Бодя, як справжній чоловік, до якоїсь
певної міри терпить, а далі показує свій характер.
Христина. Бачите, вона настільки світленька,
насправді це підвид бурого ведмедя.
Дуже старенька ведмедиця, циркова.
Вона була навіть зіркою кіно,
якісь розважальні передачі.
Я знаю, що, здається, коли «95 квартал»
Влада Яму розігрував, то вона там
брала участь, тобто вона була зіркою
і ясно, що господар її не хотів віддавати,
більше того, він тримав її в автобусі.
Ми звернулись і до активістів,
і до екологічної інспекції Львівської області
з проханням втрутитись і вилучити,
і припинити цю експлуатацію.
Ми маємо перелік ведмедів,
які в неволі по всій Україні.
Наприклад, в нашому списку зараз близько до 40 тварин.
На сьогодні ми говоримо про десяток ведмедів,
яких ми прийняли вже і наступного року
ми плануємо розширюватися.
Ми будемо будувати ще два великих лісові вольєри,
ми можемо ще прийняти додатково 5-6 тварин.
На сьогодні...
Ця територія (ми називаємо її «перша фаза розвитку»),
нашого притулку охоплює 7,9 гектара,
це три великі вольєри, кожен, приблизно, по 1,5 гектара
і ми маємо чотири реабілітаційні вольєри, кожен 1000 м².
Підведена вода
електрика, відповідні доріжки мають бути зроблені.
Наступного року ми плануємо будувати два лісових вольєри,
ще один ведмежий будинок.
А взагалі, проєкт розрахований на 20 років
і одне із планів:
ми хочемо збудувати
«Величезний освітній центр дикої природи».
У нас, наприклад, практично немає спеціалістів,
одиниці по догляду за хижими тваринами.
Наш проєкт насамперед є
освітньо-пізнавальний, екологічний.
Організовуючи екскурсіїї, ми вчимо наших відвідувачів,
як ставитися до дикої природи.
Притулок цікавий тим, що ви можете побачити все,
як впринципі відбувається в природі.
Ми спілкуємося з людьми, які до нас приходять.
Після відвідування нашого притулку вони кажуть: «Ми вже
не поведемо дітей в цирк, ми бачимо, як це відбувається,
ми бачимо, що це тварин використовують,
щоб задовільнити якійсь такі миттєві потреби людей».
Ще дуже важливо, щоби коли люди це бачать,
вони переоцінюють, переосмислюють
і, дійсно, міняється ставлення до природи.
І, таким чином,  що більша буде критична маса людей,
які розуміють, що в природу втручатися не можна,
то збільшиться чи вернеться популяція тварин,
які проживають в диких умовах.